so when you look out at the stars at
night it's amazing what you can see it's
beautiful but what's more amazing is
what you can't see because what we know
now is that around every star or almost
every star there's a planet or probably
a few so what this picture isn't showing
you are all the planets that we know
about out there in space but when we
think about planets we tend to think of
faraway things that are very different
from our own but here we are on a planet
and there are so many things that are
amazing about Earth that we're searching
far and wide to find things that are
like that and when we're searching we're
finding amazing things but I want to
tell you about an amazing thing here on
earth and that is that every minute 400
pounds of hydrogen and almost seven
pounds of helium escaped from earth into
space and this is gas that is going off
and never coming back so hydrogen helium
and many other things make up what's
known as the Earth's atmosphere the
atmosphere is just these gases that form
a thin blue line that's seen here from
the International Space Station a
photograph that some astronauts took and
this tenuous veneer around our planet is
what allows life to flourish it protects
our planet from too many impacts from
meteorites and the like and it's such an
amazing phenomenon that the fact that
it's disappearing should frighten you at
least a little bit so this process is
what's something that I study and it's
called atmospheric escape so atmospheric
escape is not specific to Planet Earth
it's part of what it means to be a
planet if you ask me because planets not
just here on earth but throughout the
universe can undergo atmosphere
escape and the way it happens actually
tells us about planets themselves
because when you think about the solar
system you might think about this
picture here and you would say well
there are eight planets maybe nine so
for those of you who are stressed by
this picture I will add somebody for you
courtesy of New Horizons we're including
Pluto and the thing here is for the
purposes of this talk and Atmospheric
escape Pluto is a planet in my mind in
the same way that planets around other
stars that we can't see are also planets
so fundamental characteristics of
planets include the fact that their
bodies that are bound together by
gravity so it's a lot of material just
stuck together with this attractive
force and these bodies are so big and
have so much gravity that's why they're
round so when you look at all of these
including Pluto they're round so you can
see that gravity is really at play here
but another fundamental characteristic
about planets is what you don't see here
and that's the star the Sun but all of
the planets in the solar system are
orbiting around and that's fundamentally
driving atmospheric escape the reason
that fundamentally stars drive
atmospheric escape from planets is
because stars offer planets particles
and light and heat that can cause the
atmospheres to go away so if you think
of a hot air balloon or you look at this
picture of lanterns in Thailand at a
festival you can see that hot air can
propel gases upward and if you have
enough energy in heating which our Sun
does that gas which is so light and only
bound by gravity it can escape into
space and so this is what's actually
causing atmospheric escape here on earth
and also on other planets that interplay
between heating from the star and
overcoming the force of gravity on the
planet so I've told you that it happens
at the rate of 400 pounds a minute for
hydrogen and almost seven pounds for
helium but what does that look
well even in the 80s we took pictures of
the earth in the ultraviolet using
NASA's dynamic Explorer spacecraft so
these two images of the earth show you
what that glow of escaping hydrogen
looks like shown in red and you can also
see other features like oxygen and
nitrogen in that white glimmer in a
circle showing you the Aurora's and also
some wisps around the tropics so these
are pictures that conclusively show us
that our atmosphere isn't just tightly
bound to us here on earth but it's
actually reaching out far into space and
at an alarming rate I might add but the
earth is not alone and undergoing
atmospheric escape Mars our nearest
neighbour is much smaller than Earth so
it has much less gravity with which to
hold on to its atmosphere and so even
though Mars has an atmosphere we can see
it's much thinner than the Earth's just
look at the surface you see craters
indicating that it didn't have an
atmosphere that could stop those impacts
also we see that it's the red planet an
atmospheric escape plays a role in Mars
being red that's because we think Mars
used to have a wetter past and when
water had enough energy it broke up into
hydrogen and oxygen and hydrogen being
so light it escaped into space and the
oxygen that was left oxidized or rusted
the ground making that that familiar
rusty red color that we see so it's time
to look at pictures of Mars and say that
atmospheric escape probably happened but
nASA has a probe that's currently at
Mars called the maven satellite and it's
actual job is to study atmospheric
escape it's the Mars atmosphere and
volatile evolution spacecraft and
results from it have already shown
pictures very similar to what you've
seen here on earth we've long known that
Mars was losing its atmosphere but we
have some stunning pictures so here for
example you can see in the red circle is
the size of Mars and in blue you can see
the hydrogen escaping away from the
planet so it's reaching out more than 10
times the size of the planet far enough
away that it's no longer bound to that
planet it's escaping off into space
and this helps us confirm ideas like why
Mars is red from that lost hydrogen the
hydrogen isn't the only gas that's lost
I mentioned helium on earth and some
oxygen and nitrogen and from maven we
can also look at the oxygen being lost
from Mars and you can see that because
oxygen is heavier it can't get as far as
the hydrogen but it's still escaping
away from the planet you don't see it
all confined into that red circle so the
fact that we not only see atmospheric
escape on our own planet but we can
study it elsewhere and send spacecraft
allows us to learn about the past of
planets but also about planets in
general and Earth's future so one way we
actually can learn about the future is
by planets so far away that we can't see
and I should just note though before I
go on to that I'm not going to show you
photos like this of Pluto which might be
disappointing but that's because we
don't have them yet but the New Horizons
mission is currently studying
atmospheric escape being lost in the
planet so stay tuned and look out for
that but the planets that I did want to
talk about are known as transiting
exoplanets so any planet orbiting a star
that's not our Sun is called an
exoplanet or extrasolar planet and these
planets that we call transiting have the
special feature that if you look at that
star in the middle you'll see that
actually it's blinking and the reason
that it's blinking is because there are
planets that are going past it all the
time and it's that special orientation
where the planets are blocking the light
from the star that allows us to see that
light blinking and by surveying the
stars in the night sky for this blinking
motion we are able to find planets this
is how we've now been able to detect
over 5,000 planets in our own Milky Way
and we know there are many more out
there like I mentioned so when we look
at the light from these stars what we
see like I said is not the planet itself
but you actually see a dimming of the
light that we can record in time so the
light drops as the planet decreases in
front of the star and that's that
blinking that you saw before so not only
do we detect the planets but we can look
at this light in different wavelengths
so I mentioned looking at the Earth and
Mars in ultraviolet light
if we look at transiting exoplanets with
the Hubble Space Telescope we find that
in the ultraviolet you seem much bigger
blinking much less light from the star
when the planet is passing in front and
we think this is because you have an
extended atmosphere of hydrogen all
around the planet that's making it look
puffier and thus blocking more of the
light that you see so using this
technique we've actually been able to
discover a few transiting exoplanets
that are undergoing atmospheric escape
and these planets can be called hot
Jupiters for some of the ones we've
found and that's because their gas
planets like Jupiter but they're so
close to their star about a hundred
times closer than Jupiter and because
there's all this lightweight gas that's
ready to escape and all this heating
from the star you have completely
catastrophic rates of atmospheric escape
so unlike our 400 pounds per minute of
hydrogen being lost on earth for these
planets
you're losing 1.3 billion pounds of
hydrogen every minute so you might think
well does this make the planet cease to
exist and this is a question that people
wondered when they looked at our solar
system because planets closer to the Sun
are rocky and planets further away are
bigger and more gaseous could you have
started with something like Jupiter that
was actually close to the Sun and get
rid of all of the gas in it we now think
that if you start with something like a
hot Jupiter
you actually can't end up with mercury
or the earth but if you started with
something smaller it's possible that
enough gas would have thought in the way
that it would have significantly
impacted it and left you with something
very different than what you started
with so all of the sounds sort of
general and we might think about the
solar system but what does this have to
do with us here on earth well in the far
future the Sun is going to get brighter
and as that happens the heating that we
find from the Sun is going to become
very intense in the same way that you
see - streaming off from a hot Jupiter
gas is going to stream off from the
earth and so what we can look forward to
or at least prepare for is the fact that
in the far future the earth is going to
look more like Mars our hydrogen from
water that's broken
is going to escape into space more
rapidly and we're going to be left with
this dry reddish planet so don't fear
it's not for a few billion years so
there's some time to prepare but I
wanted you to be aware of what's going
on not just in the future but
atmospheric escape is happening as we
speak so there's a lot of amazing
science that you hear about happening in
space and planets that are far away and
we are studying these planets to learn
about these worlds but as we learn about
Mars or exoplanets like hot Jupiters we
find things like atmospheric escape that
tell us a lot more about our planet here
on earth so consider that the next time
you think that space is far away thank
you
[Applause]